Will Ferrell gave the commencement
speech at is on modern us see now he's
known as a doctor right up there with
dr. Phil dr. Ruth dr. J dr. Drew he's
doctor Will Ferrel who joins us now
doctor congratulations thank you Dan
you forgot Doctor Zhivago I did I did
yeah do you feel different today knowing
that you're a doctor not only do I feel
different but I think people are
treating me differently when I walk into
a room there's a yeah there's just a
sense of someone of great importance is
now in their presence do people wash
your hands for you or put on gloves like
you know when your doctor you're getting
ready for surgery
here when you have to scrub up yeah yeah
just did that happen this morning but
your wife my if I forgot to scrub up and
do thank you for reminding me if I'm
going to but I have I am proud to
announce I've already performed one
elective surgery I was elective I did a
tonsillectomy yeah on a guy who didn't
want it but yeah I got it I got to
remember I've got a hygiene is a
physician's best friend who were the
luminaries up there on the dais with you
and UNC well that's what that's what
made kind of the the whole day slightly
preposterous in terms of receiving the
doctorate because I was up there with a
gentleman by the name of David David
Howe who in 1996 was Time Magazine's Man
of the Year for basically invading the
drug cocktail that that uh you know
fought off aids there was a gentleman
dr. Gary Michaelson who has over a
thousand patents in the medical world
there is a gentleman who's a huge city
councilman in Los Angeles and also
another huge benefactor of the
University and then there's Dame Helen
Mirren and myself it's pretty impressive
group there yeah you didn't feel a lot
of place did you well I made I made a
point in my speech that we all stand on
equal footing that I went through their
list of achievements I cited mine which
include running through the streets
naked of Montrose in the major motion
picture old school and and picking gum
off the ground and elf and eating it so
so yeah it was when I got the list when
I was writing my speech I wanted to know
who else was receiving the doctor Vanda
and it was it was it was very silly that
hadn't been said it was a it was a great
great day very fun why did you go to
college in the first place well you know
if I if I could look into the crystal
ball there's really no reason you're
right like what was your reason you you
went into sports information I went into
sports I was going to be you Dan I was
going to be sitting next to you on the
desk you and Oberman we were going to be
best buddies if you could trade careers
but I but I got sidetracked no but if
you could trade careers you could be a
great sports caster you could be Bob
Costas or right you could do what you do
uh I would well I would I would do what
I do know I'm not gonna lie to you okay
but I would I would I think I would spot
on occasion I would come in and and
announce the masters with Jim Nantz you
know I would pick and choose my my
sports moments where I could also jump
in on the broadcast well you have to
have that master's voice do you have
that dr. I the the dulcet tones yeah
Jimmy damn yeah so if I throw it out to
you at 70 ragin Cajun name yeah hello
friends hello for it let's go out to dr.
Will Farrell who's at 17 doctor I'm at
17 not it not it not it you can barely
hear anything except my voice
and no that's creepy that's not good I'm
wearing women's lingerie I'm 17 again
I'm being removed from 17 being placing
it on my car taken to the local local
authorities did you play you played you
picked up golf and college didn't you at
USC did you guys play at USC I I I
picked up golf by sneaking onto the
Rancho San Joaquin Golf Course in Irvine
California as a as a a high school
freshman so I I spot played throughout
my my college career but I thought when
you were in college didn't you guys play
at a course that was near a mental
institution
well that was post yeah that was post
college it so you did plate it was a
golf course by a mental institution it
just happened to be I mean it wasn't we
didn't pick it for that reason
yeah it wasn't hard our course of choice
it happened to be just a very
inexpensive place to play we're talking
to a dr. Will Ferrell he has a movie the
house is coming out with Amy Poehler on
June 30th and then you were working on
daddy's home - yes currently I'm here in
Boston oh you are in Boston okay yeah
finishing up our last week and with
myself and Mark Wahlberg John let's go
and and Mel Gibson I saw Entertainment
Tonight Kevin Frazier out there
interviewing you guys sure and it looks
Mel Gibson look like he's in pretty good
[ __ ] yeah he's a he got he got yoked up
to to be on the same level he plays
Mark's dad so and Mark is always in
fairly decent shape so he Mel looks good
have you ever been yoked up if you hide
and not yank not not I can't say that I
have
I looked at some someone sent me a photo
of a bunch of buddies of mine from high
school kind of one of those summers in
between when he come home from college
and we were all playing pick-up
basketball we all had our shirts off and
I was like
Wow I look pretty good those were the
days who didn't only who do we have on
who would Kevin Frazier said he had
played pickup hoops with you yeah and he
said that from 15 feet you got a really
nice mid-range jumper as long as no one
guards yes yeah if you leave me open
yeah I'll knock it down
but do but the bigger the celebrity the
more you guard or the less you guard oh
uh
because you don't want to hurt them yeah
or you want to make them feel good oh I
will see I play east Russian defense on
everyone though yeah but who have you
played you play with Clooney did you
ever play in those games I never play I
never
I've had a I've had a couple battles
with Woody Harrelson helis Woodrow wood
Rose got a good little handle but I can
pretty much second I can I can create
havoc archive link I've length so I can
I can alter his shot does he spark up at
halftime he does not he does not okay
no he doesn't have to because he just
has some sort of solution they rub him
before is that is that the clear that's
the clear eeeh yeah I am faced by the
way the house dad convinces his friends
start an illegal casino in his basement
after he and his wife spend their
daughters college fund not that that's
right why you came on you were no that's
not why no you you guys are nice to
mention it but no I came on to to be on
your show also a happy birthday right
yeah thank you yeah yeah don't do
it's kind of like a no-hitter we'll we
weren't going to mention it
oh okay but you just mentioned it
so did I blow it yeah so I had a
no-hitter for seven and now I just gave
up I gave up a home run I hope you're
happy and do not whatever you do do what
you did last year for my birthday that
was above and beyond so don't even think
about doing that all right okay you
promise no problem I will refrain okay
uh Paulie you mutt what's the I team huh
we have a picture of will from his
fraternity days in college the hair is
almost I mean it's almost blonde he's
got a plaid shirt and a tweed checkered
jacket on any slán yeah that might be
that might be my photo from the
fraternity that's it yeah no I was I was
much blonder are your tips frosted
natural highlights no never never
are you sure ever uh how dare you sorry
doctor yeah baby
maybe a little lemon juice oh yeah I
remember that you know son in but no
never professionally and yeah Paulie
just said you look really serious like
that face you could anchor the nightly
news not just at saying words uh that
was my game face
everyone else from the fraternity that I
met business did you ever did you ever
have game uh with the ladies yeah not
not so much no no at what point did you
realize maybe you did it wasn't until
maybe my days on Sara Night Live then it
was different then it was different
right so it still wasn't an accurate
assessment that's when Sheri Oteri
looked at you differently
exactly um and by the way our three-year
marriage that no one else's me I will
always love you was a nice touch a big
shout-out to Whitney Houston at the end
of your skin what was the other song you
thought about doing if that was the one
you settled on you know that one for
some strange reason just instantly
popped into my head and and I it was
just
divine inspiration but I did the evening
before they have what's called the
president's dinner hosted by the
president of the University and I in my
remarks I did I did say that that the
following day speech was going to be
very interesting in quotes which the
room was filled with nervous laughter
and so when I'm as I'm seeing Whitney
Houston I'm thinking oh that I know I
could tell the students were liking it
but I don't know if the faculty is
saying let's let's remember not to
invite someone similarly like this guy
well your doctor now you don't need us I
hear ya but I know I'll think of you
every step of the way
[Music]
[Music]
well that's beautiful it's fritzy
jealous
extremely he's got the pipe know he's
singing along right now but his
microphones not on his eyes are closed
he's singing along with you I also in
the mid part of the speech I sang the
theme to Star Trek as well it's like to
be part of my stand-up oh you did Star
Trek because didn't Bill Murray do Star
Wars he did Star Wars where he put in
lyrics to a song that has no lyrics I
would just literally if you if you
remember the the episodes of Star Trek
it always started with that that weird
falsetto voice how did it go so I sang
that one too I think I remember that I
think I am the red well congratulations
it's a great honor and just proud to say
I know you thanks doctor sorry I ruined
the no-hitter today don't worry about it
no and what am I supposed to know don't
know do not do not no good deed goes
unpunished you literally do what you did
last year for my birthday I hope that
cannot be embarrassing I'm okay making
sure the Palomino gets back on that Maya
crane my garage is not big enough for
another gift like that so but thank you
thank you all right I'll tell Wahlberg
we settle oh I sure will okay that's
doctor doctor Will Ferrell the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience